>>> CNN HAS NEW REPORTING ON THE
ALLEGATIONS PUSHED BY ELON MUSK
THAT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT ORDERED
TWITTER TO SUPPRESS STORIES
ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN, HIS LAPTOP
AND HIS EMAILS.
EVAN PEREZ JOINS ME WITH WHAT A
CNN INVESTIGATION AS UNCOVERED.
EVAN, LET'S START WITH THE
BOTTOM LINE HERE, WHICH IS THAT
ELON MUSK SAYS THAT THESE
TWITTER FILES SHOW THE
GOVERNMENT ORDERED TWITTER TO
SEN MacCRORY A "NEW YORK POST"
STORY IN 2020 ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN'S LAPTOP.
DO THESE INTERNAL FILES IN CNN'S
REPORTING SHOW THIS?
>> THEY DO NOT.
KATE, LOOK, WE SPENT SOME TIME,
MYSELF, DONIE O'SULLIVAN AND
OTHERS TALKING TO PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE CONVERSATION, BOTH
TECH EXECUTIVES AND THE FBI.
WE'VE LOOKED AT THESE TWITTER
FILES THAT HAVE BEEN RELEASED BY
A GROUP OF JOURNALISTS THAT ELON
MUSK CHOSE TO SHARE SOME OF
THESE INTERNAL DOCUMENTS AND
WHAT EMERGES FROM THAT IS NO
DIRECT ORDER FROM THE FBI TO
TWITTER TO SUPPRESS THE STORY
WHICH WAS DONE FOR A FEW DAYS
AHEAD OF THE -- IN OCTOBER OF
2020.
INSTEAD WHAT APPEARS TO HAVE
HAPPENED IS TWITTER EXECUTIVES
WERE PRIMED.
THEY WERE READY FOR WHAT THEY
THOUGHT WAS COMING, WHICH WAS A
RUSH IN DISINFORMATION EFFORT
AND THOUGHT THIS WAS IT.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT OBVIOUSLY
EMERGES -- YOU CAN SEE A LOT OF
CONFUSION IN THE BEHIND THE
SCENES AT TWITTER AS THEY WERE
TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH WHAT TO
DO ABOUT THE STORY.
THEY ALL ADMIT IT WAS A MISTAKE
TO SUPPRESS THAT STORY BUT
THERE'S ENOUGH IN THESE FILES TO
RAISE QUESTIONS AND I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS ARE
LATCHING ON TO, CERTAINLY JAMES
BAKER IS A FORMER FBI OFFICIAL
WHO IS NOW -- WHO WAS WORKING AT
TWITTER AT THE TIME, HE HAS
SINCE BEEN FIRED AND I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE AN EFFORT TO
GET MORE COMMUNICATIONS BECAUSE
SOMETHING COULD EMERGE FROM
ADDITIONAL SEARCHING BY THE
REPUBLICANS.
>> AND CAN WE JUST DIG INTO A
COUPLE OF THE OTHER MAJOR
ALLEGATIONS?
THERE'S A LOT TO THIS.
I WANT TO EXPLAIN AND YOU'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB.
THE MAJOR ALLEGATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE BY THE REPORTERS WITH
WHOM MUSK HAS CHOSEN TO SHARE
THESE INTERNAL DOCUMENTS WITH.
ONE IS THAT THE DAY BEFORE THE
"NEW YORK POST" PUBLISHES AN FBI
AGENT USES A SECURE CHANNEL TO
SEND OVER A BATCH OF DOCUMENTS
TO A TWITTER EXECUTIVE.
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT?
>> Reporter: THERE WERE TEN
DOCUMENTS BEING SENT BY AN FBI
AGENT IN SAN FRANCISCO TO A
HIGH-LEVEL EXECUTIVE AT TWITTER
AND WHAT YOU SEE THERE ACCORDING
TO ONE OF THE TWEETS OF THESE
TWITTER FILES, THERE IS SOME
INSINUATION THAT THERE WAS SOME
PERHAPS SOME ORDER THAT WAS
BEING SENT FROM THE FBI.
THIS IS THE DAY BEFORE THE "NEW
YORK POST" STORY PUBLISHES.
WE TALKED TO THE FBI AND FBI
OFFICIAL TOLD US EIGHT OF THOSE
WERE ACTUALLY RELATED TO
MALIGNED FOREIGN INFLUENCES AND
STUFF THAT THE FBI ROUTINELY
SENDS TO SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
SAYING HERE IS SOME INFORMATION
ABOUT SOME ACCOUNTS THAT ARE
POSTING THINGS THAT MAY BE
CONNECTED TO A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT.
YOU DO WHATEVER YOU WANT TO DO
WITH IT.
THIS IS UP TO YOU.
TWO OF THE DOCUMENTS DID HAVE TO
DO WITH AN INVESTIGATION ON
POSSIBLE ELECTION OR VOTER
SUPPRESSION SO THAT'S THE
EXPLANATION FOR THOSE TEN
DOCUMENTS.
>> ANOTHER CLAIM IS THAT TWITTER
WAS GETTING PAID MILLIONS BY THE
FBI.
HAVE YOU FOUND ANYTHING ON THAT?
>> Reporter: $3.4 MILLION
ACCORD -- YOU'LL SEE A TWEET
THAT EXPLAINS THAT THERE IS SOME
PERHAPS SOME CONNECTION IN THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN TWITTER AND
THE FBI.
THE FBI SAYS THAT UNDER FEDERAL
LAW COMPANIES ARE ALLOWED TO
SEEK REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE COST
THEY INCUR TO RESPOND TO FBI
RECORDS REQUEST, FOR INSTANCE,
SUBPOENAS IF THEY HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH ANYTHING THAT THE FBI IS
ORDERING THEM TO SUPPLY AS PART
OF AN INVESTIGATION THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO SEEK REIMBURSEMENT OF
THAT AND THAT GOES ACROSS THE
BOARD FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS LIKE
PHONE COMPANIES AND SO ON SO
TWITTER IS ONE OF THOSE
COMPANIES AND THAT FIGURE IS
WHAT THAT EXPLAIN, $3.4 MILLION.
>> AND JUST KIND OF ON --
STEPPING BACK A LITTLE BIT AND
LOOKING AT JUST HOW MUCH --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF FOCUS ON
HOW MUCH INTERACTION WAS GOING
ON BETWEEN TWITTER AND THE FBI.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY THE FBI IS
EVEN DOING THIS?
>> YEAH, SO THE FBI SAYS AND
TWITTER SAYS THAT ALL OF THIS IS
IN PART BECAUSE OF 2016, RIGHT?
WHERE THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
FOUND THAT RUSSIANS, THE RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES USED
SOCIAL MEDIA TO HELP INTERFERE
WITH U.S. ELECTIONS AND THAT
INCLUDES THE HACKING OF
DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGNS DUMPING
FILES THAT WERE INTENDED TO HURT
THE CANDIDACY OF HILLARY CLINTON
AND HELP DONALD TRUMP SO THE
COMPANIES AND THE FBI WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
STOP THAT FROM HAPPENING AGAIN
IN 2020 AND SO THAT'S WHAT YOU
SEE IN SOME OF THESE TWITTER
FILES THAT HAVE BEEN PUBLISHED.
I'LL READ PART OF THE STATEMENT
PUSHING BACK ON THESE CLAIMS
FROM ELON MUSK AND OTHERS AND
THEY SAY THIS IS PART OF THE
TRADITIONAL EFFORT THAT THE FBI
MAKES TO WORK WITH SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES AND THEY SAY IT IS
UNFORTUNATE THAT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND OTHERS ARE FEEDING
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
MISINFORMATION WITH THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF ATTEMPTING TO
DISCREDIT THE AGENCY, THE BOTTOM
LINE FROM THE FBI IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, THERE IS NOTHING THAT HAS
EMERGED THAT SHOWS THEM GOING
OVER THE LINE.
KATE, IT'S CLEAR, THOUGH, WE'LL
HEAR A LOT MORE OF THIS BECAUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE PROMISING TO
INVESTIGATE THIS STUFF EVEN
THOUGH AT THIS POINT, YOU KNOW,
SOME OF THE JOURNALISTS THAT
HAVE BEEN DIGGING DEEP ON BEHALF
OF ELON MUSK HAVE SO FAR SAID
THAT THERE WAS NO DIRECT ORDER
FROM THE FBI TO SENSOR THESE
STORIES.
>> GREAT WORK, EVAN, THANKS SO
MUCH.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
IT ON.